[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo que respirar
alguna vez se han preguntado qué hacen
con las cosas que te pasan
cuál es la historia que se cuentan sobre
sus vidas
cuando yo tenía 12 años a mí me
encantaba bailar adoraba bailar
recuerdo una mañana de verano una mañana
que estaba de vacaciones del cole y que
estaba ensayando un baile estaba
ensayando un baile
porque había cogido como costumbre que
mi padre al volver del trabajo
él le gustaba escuchar música y yo lo
que hacía era bailar
esta mañana mientras estaba ensayando
sonó el teléfono sonó el teléfono y
llamaban del trabajo de mi padre lo
contestó el teléfono en aquella época no
había móviles
normal yo contestó el teléfono y me
dicen oye que tu padre se siente mal
que la vieja tu madre para que lo vayas
a buscar
pues así lo hago yo mi madre no estaba
en casa estaba en casa de la vecina
yo fui de llevar como más mira que
hacemos estos se visten y los pasó
buscando que nos vamos al trabajo de tu
padre
yo estaba con mi hermano mi hermano
tenía 15 años en aquella época y así lo
hicimos nos fuimos al trabajo de mi
padre estamos hablando de que yo vivía
en caracas
yo soy venezolana vivía en caracas en
caracas la distancia más corta pueden
ser fácilmente 30 40 minutos gente el
tráfico el atasco y todo por fin
llegamos al trabajo de mi madre de mi
padre perdón y desde la puerta nos dicen
sigan sigan sigan que se lo llevaron al
hospital y así lo hicimos 20 minutos más
mi madre llegan separan la puerta del
hospital
y pregunta en información con conmigo y
con mi hermano y le dice el señor pedro
barroso
un momento no había ordenadores tampoco
año 88 la chica vuelve
vuelvo y le dice mire señora su marido
su marido está en el sótano dos bajando
a la derecha
yo creo que mi mamá en aquel momento no
fue consciente
de lo que te acaban de contar
nada bajamos bajamos al sótano
y cuando bajamos lo recuerdo que vuelve
a pedir una razón de él y en ese momento
la razón fue que le entregaron una bolsa
una bolsa con los pantalones de mi papá
con la camisa de mi papá y con todas las
cosas personales de él lo que había
pasado es que le había dado un infarto
le había dado un infarto
eso fue lo que sucedió
pero la historia
la historia realmente las historias son
la primera que me quede huérfana con 12
años que pasamos de una familia de
tenerlo todo a no tener absolutamente
nada mi madre mi madre con 44 años se
unió totalmente en una depresión porque
es como a su menos una ayuda es con 44
años con dos chicos adolescentes mi
hermano mi hermano se encerró en una
habitación y no salió de ahí por dos
años yo comencé a trabajar a los 15 años
y la segunda historia que es la historia
que yo quiero compartir con ustedes que
es mi historia es que mi padre me dejó
un legado maravilloso
mi padre quizás no me lo enseñó pero si
con sus hechos
mi padre volvía del trabajo y escuchaba
música y no importa si estuviese cansado
con lo que sea él se sentaba y me veía
bailar lo contábamos los minutos de los
viernes porque los viernes para era
maravilloso era crear una experiencia
nueva
y yo ayer llamé a mi hermano a pedirle
permiso para hacer de mi papá de pasar
tantos años ahora tengo 43 años
y le digo que voy a hablar es una charla
que
es un recuento de la historia es que es
una trayectoria y me dices ya susana
pero es que fue una putada lo que nos
pasó y yo le dije mira es que tú
decidiste quedarte con una parte de la
historia y yo decidí quedarme con otra
se dan cuenta como en la vida lo
importante no es lo que te pasa sino lo
que haces con lo que te pasa mire mi
padre con 80 años le dicen que le
quedaban dos meses de vida que hizo él
en vez de lamentarse disgustarse se
dedicó a despedirse de todas las
personas que había conocido amigos
familiares que había conocido durante
toda su vida la verdad que fue increíble
imagínense movió cielo y tierra para
localizar el teléfono de un tal ya no
nadie se acordaba de echarlo en la
familia lo localiza llama a un cuñado a
las hermanas y cuando lo tiene imágenes
en la cara del señor cuando mi padre lo
llama y le dice hola ya no soy moisés yo
no sé si te acuerdas de mí hace 40 años
que no nos vemos tu trabajo te conmigo
en un bar en tejeda y te estoy llamando
porque te quiero decir que estoy mal o
me estoy muriendo y te quiero agradecer
que no me has robado nunca el valor de
una perra chica que se quedó muerto
impresionado y además no se lo debió
creer
porque mi padre luego decía que si ya no
qué verdad preguntar a mis hijas y
nosotras no papá por favor no nos lo
pases también llama antonio antonio iba
todos los días a la playa con él mi
padre era un señor de campo que se vino
de tejeda con 65 o 70 años y iba todos
los días a las 7 de la mañana la prima
decía él a bañarse a la playa iba con
antonio y los llamé y le dice imagínense
la cara de antonio antonio yo no me más
a la playa tú sabes que estoy mal o
bueno me estoy muriendo la verdad
despídete de pepe y dejuan porque yo no
lo voy a ver más y otra cosa antonio
cuídate porque está gordo que gracias a
lo que yo me he cuidado estoy llevando
esta enfermedad bien antonio sorprendido
nosotros sorprendida mi madre
sorprendida un día se levanta y dice hoy
vamos al médico hoy quiero ir al
hospital insular a hablar con el médico
después vamos vistan se mis hijas
pónganse guapa hoy vamos a hablar con el
médico se sienta llega al médico
y le plantea que que tenía que hacer
para donar el cuerpo a la ciencia que él
y quería a duelo ni quería velatorio ni
quería incineraciones que él quería que
siguieran aprendiendo algo de él mi
padre decidió vivir la muerte con
valentía
yo soy valiente gracias a él de hecho
después de de ese momento la actitud mi
manera de afrontar la vida ha cambiado
totalmente y hace siete años hace siete
años de eso se trata de de estas dos
historias se tratan de eso de cómo
afrontamos las cosas que nos pasan
normalmente cuántos de ustedes aquí a
ver levanten la mano cuando tienen un
problema lo primero que hacen es
quejarse aquí yo me quejo normalmente
que hacemos nos quejamos yo creo que
todos nos hemos quejado en algún momento
dos estados nos quejamos pero queremos
dejarles que realmente pueden hacer tres
cosas mal es cuando tenemos una
situación un problema lo que sea la
primera opción modo queja
es que mi marido es que el niño es que
no tengo tiempo es que está lloviendo es
que yo culpamos a alguien siempre
estamos en modo quejarnos y solucionemos
que ya no hay nada es que no se avanza
otra manera de afrontar las cosas en
modo parálisis
me peleé con virtudes
le damos la vuelta de problemas no te
preocupes que esquema del tiempo lo cura
todo realmente el tiempo cura los
problemas
o le estamos dando la espalda pero
clusterina vamos sabemos lo que tenemos
que hacer y no lo hacemos
si es que
es que yo no sé yo no puedo estamos en
esas dos partes todo el tiempo todo el
tiempo yo no sé yo no puedo qué tal si
avanzamos y nos pasamos a otro lado que
es cambiar el you nos ella y yo no puedo
por cómo puedo hacer para conseguirlo
mientras nosotros que es el modo avanzar
es un modo que te hace fuerte es un modo
en donde empiezas en vez y cambias las
lamentaciones por preguntas preguntas
que te consigan o que te den con la
respuesta la respuesta a lo mejor no lo
sabemos porque no no sabemos todo pero
si tú quieres lograr algo a lo mejor
alguien ya lo hizo si uno piensa algún
chino alimento todo está hecho en google
buscamos la idea es
no piensen en el problema o traten por
lo menos de no pensarlo en queja y en
parálisis problemas si solamente con el
solo hecho de ponernos a pensar un
poquito en la solución
ya está un poquito mejor y es que la
vida son decisiones son las decisiones
que tomamos ustedes se preguntarán y por
qué unas personas deciden ser felices y
otras no o porque unas personas deciden
unas cosas y otras no cómo se forman las
decisiones pues es muy fácil las
decisiones se forman con un enfoque y un
significado concreto y ahora se
preguntarán y qué es el enfoque pues el
enfoque es tu pensamiento a aquello a lo
que le prestas atención
susana cuando falleció su padre lo vivió
de una manera completamente diferente a
su familia ella se enfocó en la fuerza
en la pasión y en el legado que le había
dejado su padre sin embargo su madre y
su hermano se enfocaron en la pérdida de
la desgracia que suponía perder a su
padre tan joven ellos se quedaron en el
terrible problema y ella apostó por las
soluciones
que el significado el significado en la
interpretación que hacemos de todo lo
que nos pasa por ejemplo un día lluvioso
para una persona puede ser maravilloso
imagínense en el día en casa la camita
acostado la chimenea lectura pero para
otro para otro puede ser un auténtico
desastre ahora no puedo salir de mi casa
está lloviendo no puede ir a la que no
pudiera la calle a ver quién aguanta a
los chiquillos hoy en casa se me cae en
la casa mi padre vivió su muerte como
una oportunidad para conectar con todas
aquellas personas que había conocido
durante toda su vida ustedes se han
preguntado alguna vez en qué se enfocan
y qué significado le dan a las cosas que
le pasa se lo han preguntado vamos a ver
vamos a pensarlo la gente un examen un
suspenso
me despiden del trabajo en mi relación
con mi pareja
vamos a ver pensemos un minutito en que
nos enfocamos en como en el problema o
es la solución en que pensamos en lo que
tengo para resolverlo en lo que me falta
me voy al pasado que ya no existe y no
puedo hacer nada o vengo al presente qué
significado le damos a las cosas que nos
pasan un significado de injusticia un
significado de pérdida un significado de
fracaso o vivimos las cosas como una
oportunidad de crecimiento en la vida
les digo una cosa lo más importante lo
más importante en la vida es decidir
porque es una decisión en que nos
enfocamos y qué significado le damos
porque realmente ese enfoque y ese
significado lo que está haciendo
generando una emoción
y de esa emoción es cuando tomamos una
decisión lo hago no lo hago lo llamo no
lo llamo lo entrego no lo entrego me
atrevo es hacer las cosas es simplemente
tratar siempre de buscar ser nuestra
mejor versión teniendo un enfoque y un
significado un poquito mejor hay un
ejemplo que me encanta poner que es cuál
es la versión que queremos dar de
nosotros mismos cuando imagínense que
llegan de casa no descansado llegan a
casa del trabajo universidad de la calle
llega no entran que tal como estás
cansado
quiere comer bueno normalmente no a
veces nos sentamos a comer y la
conversación es muy amena todo el mundo
con el móvil
ahí también mandaron wesson mandan un
gaza y estamos en silencio pero de
pronto me llamo a virtudes abierto que
pasó mi niña como éstas se dan cuenta
como en un segundo le doy mi mejor
versión y mi sonrisa a la persona que me
llama por teléfono
y qué hago con la gente que
supuestamente se parece es la más
importante para mí que es la que tengo
al lado darle mi peor versión con un
estoy cansado es que el problema es el
problema cuando nosotros somos lo que
tenemos la decisión
de darle nuestra mejor versión y hacemos
como el padre de virtudes esperamos ya a
última hora a que vengan las malas
noticias para recordarle a las personas
que ustedes más quieren a las personas
que realmente le importan es decir te
quiero perdóname te amo
oye mira vamos a solucionar el problema
vamos a sentarnos a hacer unos solanas
del problema es simplemente afrontarlo
pero no es así además para terminar
quería que se quedaran con una frase que
yo digo todos los días
si puedo la digo y es que todos somos
seres completos
creativos y llenos de recursos para
triunfar veamos en qué nos enfocamos y
qué significado le damos a la cosa vamos
a decidir qué actitud vamos a tener ante
la vida porque recuerden lo importante
no es lo que nos pase sino es lo que
hacemos con las cosas que nos pasan
muchas gracias gracias un placer
[Aplausos]
[Música]